former deputy prime minister hello to
you my lord thank you for joining us
what do you think should happen should
i
stay
i'm absolutely clear that uh
we need a deputy prime minister to act
in the interwegnum before the new prime
minister is chosen uh it's quite obvious
that uh boris johnson if he actually
were allowed to stay uh is going to try
and put through a range of policies
which will bolster his position
presumably for another go or something
like that
so
that's unthinkable uh we're now dealing
with a very short period in which a new
leader is chosen and there will have to
be a pause in serious policy initiatives
but the the critical thing of course
here
is
that
boris is associated with one major
policy
and that is it and that is brexit and i
coined the phrase if boris goes brexit
goes
uh
to me the the big and interesting
dilemma is the way in which kirstama has
been wrong-footed in making these
anti-european speeches as he has so on
the basis that he was going to fight
boris johnson now of course the torah
party is going to have to find a new
leader and
my belief is that there will be a
return to sanity towards our policies
about europe uh which will make
kierstama look i think rather foolish
and irrelevant
but certainly boris has got to go and he
mustn't be allowed to sort of maneuver
and manipulate power in the dying days
of his premiership
but my lord you know that the
conservative party the modern
conservative party wanted to get brexit
done that's why jeremy hunt failed
when he was in the two horse race with
boris johnson 66 of those who voted
conservative members around the country
said they wanted boris johnson and the
big issue then as it is now was brexit
so any uh
potential prime minister who comes
forward will not say they want to go
back into europe
well
they won't say that but they will i
think say they want a totally more
positive relationship with europe
and if they don't then they're going to
build the opening for the lib dems in
the south of england
you see people quote what happened in
the last general election that's history
the important thing is what is happening
in the by-elections and in public
opinion and public opinion has now
seized brexit as a disaster and the lib
dems are winning safe seats from the
conservatives in the south of england on
the issue of europe amongst other things
so
if the tory party is going to have a
ghost of a chance of going through the
next few months which are going to be
very difficult economically and then
being a credible party in the next
election they're going to have to revert
to that traditional conservative
position of building a power base in the
center of british politics now don't
tell me the party has got divisions on
this subject i fully understand that but
the the extreme
anti-europeanism right-wingism is in
fact a suicide course for the torii
party in the context of the economic
circumstances we're facing
i'm going to ask you this question for
those who haven't heard me ask it before
who do you think would best fit that
role
well look i i'm fully aware that i'm
quite a controversial figure in the
torah party so my endorsement could be
toxic and therefore i will remain like a
clam silent
uh if i was depressed you might you um
indulge me
might you indulge me with a name if i
were to press you and ask you again
even faced with your charm i will remain
clam-like
[Laughter]
do you think there is enough time
between now and recess which is when all
the mps go on their summer holidays to
try to narrow down the i mean it's going
to be a wide open race isn't it for
those that would like to uh be the
incumbent at number 10 do you think
there is enough time
for conservative mps to narrow that down
whittle that down to two
oh yes if they want to and the the the
fact is they will do it very rapidly
they're going on their holidays they
won't don't want this hanging or all
over the constituencies in that time
the thing of course the trouble is and i
personally would change this rule
i think that the idea of putting two
people to the membership of the tory
party is actually a a
a mistake because the membership of the
tory party is a relatively small part of
the tory vote and it tends to be rather
activist it tends to be rather extreme
and so there is an inbuilt instinct to
go for the populist arguments that
appeal to the tory activists as opposed
to the
critical electorate which is the one in
the center ground of british politics
okay we are going to hear from the prime
minister uh to confirm what we already
know that he will be resigning today
what do you think what do you want to
hear from him
goodbye
yeah maybe a little bit more than that
potentially
well it's very difficult to know what he
can say i mean he has been a disastrous
prime minister in
the conduct of the nation's affairs
i'm fully aware that he did a perfectly
reasonable job over coping broadly the
same as all our european equivalents uh
i know he's
been
supportive of the
the ukrainian uh heroic defense and uh i
of course much support that but any
prime minister would have done the same
and um there is that awful feeling
reflected in
max hastings article in the times today
above his saw it as an opportunity of
you know boosterism bolsterism i'm a
churchill mini churchill not even a mini
jojo um
so i'm afraid the cynics
cynicism in me it tells me that billy
when it comes to it
what has boris achieved and boris has
achieved the trashing of britain's
international reputation the trashing of
the reputation of the tory party and
left us facing an economy in very
serious trouble about which
the truth needs to be told and with the
devolution agenda which has been much
talked about
actually
moving into snails pace
you are i think we're both um
i was going to say of a certain age i'm
going to say experienced and we've seen
a few of these situations previously um
can you make any comparisons between
this end of days and other tory mps
who've had to go
i think that there is one stark
comparison
and that is dignity
one in this case the latter
but i mean
the the fact i mean it is now a
significant period since michael howard
and william hague as former leaders of
the party said that the prime minister
had to go we saw that 148 of his
colleagues vote against him and there of
course were many more who would have
done so in any second round
um and and there has been this sort of
unedifying clinging to the rock
against the inevitable prising off and
it has been a very undignified process
and i can't think of any precedent from
all the leadership battles that i've
watched on the touchlines of
now nearly 50 years in public life
as unediting as this one
and my lord what would you say to um
comments that i've been reading in the
papers this morning that suggested that
if a big beast like you had still bill
in politics today he would not have
turned you away last night and said i'm
still staying in other words it's those
around him not just the prime minister
for now that is responsible for this
unedifying spectacle
i think that his colleagues should have
acted
more decisively and earlier
but i'm afraid
that i subscribed to the view that
the cabinet
is
basically
bobby's friends
uh we have not got that traditional
position of the good cabinet which
represents the wide spectrum of victoria
party thinking